[Music]
and it's the same with um with star trek
for me as well you know i grew up
watching um tng deep space nine voyager
um
i'll be honest with you guys i haven't
watched all of enterprise i i couldn't
deal with it but at the same time like
the the structure for it you know it was
very philosophical moral questions you
know um you know ds9 really pushed it to
the limit of that but there was still
this hopeful ideology behind it um and
now it's
punchy kicky shooty generic action space
tv show for me
um
during that deep space nine episode i
think it was season six
when cisco was actually talking to the
camera
oh
yeah but he teamed up with garrick in
that the very end of the episode he's
doing the captain's log in the very end
of the episode he just like delete logs
that's that's what i love about patrick
is it reflects
society a lot of the time and it
actually reflects
our best and our worst
um elements of my life i love that um
episode it's not the first time the
klingons have changed their makeup lose
it and i actually do remember they they
did that
brilliant nothing another deep space
nine i think these play nice is
seriously underrated sometimes
did that a serious when they jump back
to the original series the trouble with
tribbles
and yeah these nine characters went back
and they actually
the wharf
about that
yes yeah exactly it's really you know
what's with all the uh we don't discuss
and i think that wasn't that one of the
uh tail end uh episodes of uh enterprise
they they they covered it in enterprise
yeah they they covered that
right right right the augment dna or
something yeah yeah that's it
i i don't like the klingons now i think
they look weird
and particularly
what in discovery yeah i just think they
look but they just look hard
but at the same time i think the way
that they handle the klingons other than
yes there was the initial baldness which
they say was
part of like wartime klingon culture and
culture is uh transitional it changes um
and and i mean other than
that and the fact that they were
stockpiling the coffins as opposed to
the the shell
um attitude that they had in in
you know next generation onwards which
is if a klingon dice it's just a shell
other than that i
i actually really liked the depiction of
the klingons in discovery i think
particularly um and he was only in it
for two episodes but the activa played
to kovma
in the first two episodes
that guy sold it i mean you can tell
that guy learnt his klingon lines you
know remain klingon
boom like it was the the guttural
approach to the pronunciation and even
with those facial prosthetics like he
really sold it for me um so i actually i
saw a documentary i kept watching the
post discovery you know they did the
post discovery episodes on netflix when
it first came out yeah yeah yeah talking
klingon off
characters if you he didn't break
character and says it was really
frustrating
i was i was i was gutted that they i
mean spoiler alert but i'm i'm gutting
everyone seen it i'm gutted he died
after the second episode because that
guy was like the best klingon actor
out of anyone he put his soul into i was
i was so impressed it was amazing it was
good
really good
the um
his acting skills yeah i mean
when i first started watching discovery
you know the first time it came on you
know i signed up for cbs all access
totally ready to nerd out
and
of all the other actors he's i mean he
stole everything you didn't even know
what i mean even with all the makeup he
stole every scene he was in
it was that bit where he was saying
about when he was and i don't remember
obviously i didn't speak klingon but
like um apart from a couple of phrases
but when he was talking about he was
saying uh the federation is is is down
in the muck with the andorian and the
and the vulcans and all this and it was
it was you know the tellerites and it
was oh my god like the guy was
incredible the cool and the way he you
know he was talking about you know the
relationship between klingons and the
federation well the federation everybody
and here comes the lie
yeah you know and then um georgios says
and we come in peace
yeah well it may have it may have been i
mean in a way i i think they missed out
on an opportunity
to to compare that as almost like a borg
comparison because the way to cover saw
it was it was an assimilation of their
culture and denying them their
individuality as a spacefaring
um you know and if that's something
we've never seen like or at least i
don't remember seeing with klingons is
that attitude if you know the
federation's trying to tame us and take
our culture away you know i think
star trek losing its identity though are
we really focusing on discovery or are
we thinking as well being did actually
enterprise start down this road of
forgetting
what it was supposed to be
my personal experience i think
enterprise was just too complicated i
think they over did it
and i think if they just simplified that
storyline it could have really been
brilliant
but i think they have all the time
travel stuff and the time or things and
if they just drop that
i'm doing a series
like t and g
you know just like we're going to go to
a different planet each week we're going
to build up and they're building towards
the federation it would have been
awesome but then all this
crap they threw on top sorry
the schism between um
star or humans and vulcans god that was
delicious i thought you know
and um
how you know how the the dependence
humans had on vulcans and the submissive
role that humans had with vulcans
you know and uh especially the um
you know finding the listening post in
the uh temple oh yeah that was one of my
favorite episodes the whole thing you
know it had nothing to do with the sula
bond had nothing to do
you know i i did kind of like the um
the whole arc with the um
the zindy
you know especially
yeah production of florida and that was
kind of cool but so like i agree with
you guys the whole the time travel thing
and the zipping around and uh it's just
nonsense and then they're talking about
that that that might be coming back
through into enterprise don't they as
well you know like the um the guy from
the future whenever we saw his face he
looked kind of looked like a romulan to
me i always thought but um he was you
know like talking to the people they
think that's the guy or the one of the
fan theories is in discovery i hold her
name the the
oh georgia georgia yeah
they think it's him
they think he's the guy that is that
like the face from the future sort of
thing oh i mean i've just full
disclosure with you guys like i've seen
all of tos all of tng all of deep space
nine all of voyager i have not watched
all of enterprise i could not get on
board with it um discovery i've seen one
two and
some of three and i've seen all of
picard um but i've kind of like i ran
out of steam enterprise and i ran out of
steam with um discovery
and i've definitely run out of steam
with picard i think you should give
discovery season three another try then
mate to be fair because it's the best
series
it's really that third year
yeah it greatly improves really really
good
you know stuff the the storyline and
you're on to something new
you know it's uh
it's because
i i
really enjoy discovery season one i
really enjoyed it and i thought i would
be properly against it when it first
started because the initial episode
started and within 10 minutes we had
holograms
that's that's not all friendly and we
had the the change to the klingons and i
went yeah
screw this
and then i stuck it through i really
enjoyed the first series
i enjoyed the second series up to about
halfway through and i got fed up
um and then picard came out
and i don't know if this is a
controversial opinion the card's
freaking awful in my opinion awful awful
shame so come back in a sec but let's
just focus on disco for one second
because okay
discovery gets good
i i'm with you to be fair i didn't
really watch the end the second half of
the discovery series
and i what i did was when discovery
series three came out i thought i'm
gonna have to figure out what happened
so i sort of went back and and and got
up to but to be honest two or three
episodes i don't think i actually
watched
and i just watched enough that i knew
what the hell was going on
so i think and then i got into discovery
because i knew they'd gone into the
future so i was like i want to see
what's in the view that that's that's
good no this is really good idea
brilliant
but then it took half the series for you
to actually see the federation actually
see anything in the future that's it i
got i got two three episodes in and i
was like
sorry guys but when they do me
and the little nod the nog because
obviously the the nog actor
passed away didn't he was it last year
of the year before yes
i believe his name was
yeah
so one of the starships actually is the
nog and you actually do see it pretty
good
oh
before we started this storm uh my my
business partner mike um who i'm also on
aliens and stuff with um who
unfortunately couldn't make it today um
him and i were meant to go to
destination track
and we were going to get a
photo with nog rom and quark in full
costume and we didn't go
off till the next year but of course the
next year was covered and it was
cancelled and now unfortunately he's um
passed away so
we've got if we missed out on that
opportunity i loved noggin deep space
nine that was some real character
development right there
yeah all the all the ferengi were
brilliant in d straight no
i think d space nine might be my
favorite series
it's my favorite it's it's snuck up on
you